get out your hammers and make sure your
trap doors are properly calibrated
because it's time we discuss the
elephant in the room okay that was bad
episode 7 was an absolute bombshell of
new information so in this video we're
gonna break it all down and go over some
insane new theories you're gonna want to
stick around for the whole video since
we'll be discussing what awesome anteus
was really trying to say in his help
message throughs real father the
elephant and that big dr. Manhattan
reveal at the end of the episode so
strap on in because here we go the very
first images of the Watchmen title on an
old TV as we hear a VHS being loaded
young Angela will later keep a VHS of
sister night the blaxploitation film
which she used as inspiration for her
vigilante alter-ego this transitions us
to a short documentary explaining the
origins of dr. Manhattan fitting since
the end of this episode marks
Manhattan's return there are some cool
Easter eggs here like the new
frontiersman a far-right leaning
publication claiming fair and balanced
journalism a jab at Fox News we learned
how dr. Manhattan grew up in Germany and
immigrated to the US as a young boy now
this is interesting because we know
angela's great-grandfather served in
Germany in World War one could he have
run into Jon's parents is there a deeper
connection there that we don't know
about
regardless dr. Manhattan would later go
on to win the Vietnam War for America
giving them their 51st state speaking of
Vietnam were transported there to the
year 1987 where we meet young Angela
it's Vivi d-day or victory of Vietnam
day and people are celebrating Angela
scrolls through a selection of top-notch
VHS is like trunky over here a
foreshadowing of the elephant that's to
come we also get the film adaptation of
Fogg dancing the book mrs. Clark was
reading in episode 4 as well as silk
swingers a reference to silk swingers of
suburbia a b-movie mentioned in the
graphic novel about the original Silk
Spectre young Angela chooses sister
night notice the blue bows in her hair
blue being a common color her character
wears throughout the episode even in the
scene where lady true and Angela eat
together there's a blue fish hinting
that dr. Manhattan
has been in front of us this whole time
just hidden HBO's PDP dia page has more
info about this masked vigilante telling
us she was a devout nun by day
crime-fighting badass by night her
parents like Angela's were murdered
sister Knight is also married to God
she's a nun just like Angela is married
to a God cow we get a glimpse of a dr.
Manhattan puppet show perhaps a nod to
Manhattan's line in the comics where he
says to Lauri quote were all puppets I'm
just a puppet who can see the strings
Angela brings the tape to her parents
and her dad doesn't like the fact she
picked out a film about a masked
vigilante people who were masked a
dangerous Angela we should be scared of
him Angela's father knew firsthand the
harm being a masked vigilante can do his
father was hooded justice and we saw how
that turned out last episode Angela
witnesses her parents death a traumatic
event that will shape her into becoming
sister night she awakens from her
nostalgia trip at lady truths who has
been allowed to take care of Angela to
get her memories flushed out of her
system that's what this arm contraption
is for which as we see in the tutorial
uses a process called pneumo dialysis to
flush those memories using a new host
now we're led to believe she's connected
to her grandfather but as we'll later
find out it leads to an elephant more on
that in a bit Cal comes to see Angela
but is blocked by hologram beyond who
says due to the Millennium clock
starting soon he's not allowed in pirate
Jenny and Red Scare are here as well
since technically angela is still under
arrest in her car lori listens to a
recording of Angela's voice when she was
rambling high on nostalgia recording
this conversation has given her more
clues about Cyclops its relation to the
7th Calvary and why Judd was killed
these Clues leader - Jane Crawford who
uses a trapdoor to capture Laurie when
her plan has been discovered Jane is
working with Senator Kean in the 7th
cavalry to get their men embedded as
cops
all the while keen makes strides for the
White House never trust Rosa's mother PD
has also been sent to check up on
Looking Glass and it looks like these
men who came to attack him two episodes
ago have all been taken care of but why
did Looking Glass not call it in and why
is one of the men not wearing his mask
over the PA at throughs we hear a woman
say that were nine hours away from the
mall
named clock being activated and that all
medals should be removed
we also learned from PDP dia that true
donated free HD televisions to every
citizen of tulsa as a gift for the
disruption that construction has caused
my theory is that these TVs will be used
as a conduit to mesmerize / hypnotize
the Tulsa population its signal will be
transmitted through the millenium clock
either wiping the memories of those who
watch it or somehow infusing the
Watchers with empathy if people can
actually see what it's like and feel the
lived experiences of others kind of like
the nostalgia drug allows it may put an
end to the violence racism and hate this
idea of empathy is hinted at when BN
enters and performs her Rorschach like
test
she tells Angela her dissertation is on
the adaptive function of empathy hint
hint
Angela asks how a girl her age is so
smart but as will later find out BN is
in fact a clone of trues mother
instilled with her mother's memories in
another Angela flashback we see her at
the home for girls painting blue dr.
Manhattan nesting dolls nesting dolls
features several dolls within a doll yet
another hint of dr. Manhattan hiding
within the outer shell that is cow the
police asked her to identify the man who
helped in the attack that killed her
parents and she even asked if she can
listen to the gunfire as they kill him
the female officer gives her a badge
sparking her desire to one day become a
cop it's day 365 of the People vs Adrian
Veidt the prosecutor finishes her
closing remarks blaming Adrian for the
deaths of 3 million people in New York a
result of the squid attack / psionic
blast as well as the deaths of their
fellow clones but the biggest travesty
was breaking the one law set forth by
their creator
thou shalt not leave the courtroom is
littered with evidence like Ozzy's
spacesuit as well as a squid
illustration here which was done by an
Indian surrealist painter Ozymandias
hired to create designs for the actual
squid that would terrorize New York a
painter Ozzie would later kill to
prevent the truth from ever getting out
Adrian hasn't spoken or defended himself
throughout the entire trial in fact his
closing remarks are a fart so the game
warden has assembled a jury more suited
for a man such as Adrian
a bunch of pigs but why pigs will it
ties into philosophy specifically an
argument against utilitarianism called
the doctrine of swine objection remember
that Adriane killed millions in order to
save more in the long run it's a
utilitarian principle that one should
always choose the outcome that maximizes
happiness for the most amount of people
but the doctrine of swine objection
states that if the utilitarian principle
that people have no higher objective in
life than to pursue pleasure it shows
that people have the same goal in life
as that of a pig hence the pigs that are
brought in symbolic of Adrian and his
uncultured farting ways Adrian is found
guilty as we transition from him crying
to this statue of him at lady truths and
there was a theory out there that Ozzy
is actually trapped in that statue that
in Episode four it was his body like in
some sort of Star Wars carbonite that
lady true recovered from the Clark farm
we also get this butterfly a creature
known to emerge from a cocoon like
Adrian may emerge from that statue when
the time is right this ties in to the
theory that true is adrian veidt's
daughter continuing his legacy remember
she also took over all of his companies
plus it also supports her statement that
she wants her parents alive to see her
accomplishments I'm on the verge of
completing my life's work is it wrong to
want my parents with me when I do your
dad's here too this could also mean the
message adrian wrote on europa wasn't
saved me dr. Manhattan rather save me
daughter another theory is that Adrian
Veidt has been with lady true all along
but in a coma-like State he's in his own
prison doubt of his mind a prison he put
himself in after driving himself mad
from the memory of killing all those
people in New York we know that
nostalgia resulted in people reliving
their worst memories of their lives
unable to let go of the past
lady true maybe looking to free Adrian
from his prison this past allowing him
to come back to the real world in order
to stop the 7th Calvary from their plans
of creating a new dr. Manhattan let me
know which there you think is more
plausible or if you have your own in the
comments below
we're back with Laurie who is tied up
with a giant Cyclops image behind her it
kind of looks like it's a weird
combination of the dr. Manhattan symbol
mixed with the squid I were in the
abandoned mall that looking last
discovered a few episodes ago and some
of these true company devices have been
seen placed along the perimeter of the
portal we saw them testing keen reveals
himself to lori saying it's hard being a
white man in america today she says she
doesn't give a [ __ ] but keen quips that
she of all people should especially when
he hints that he's going to become a
blue man AKA manhattan her ex-lover my
best guess is that they are setting up
some sort of trap for manhattan in which
these true devices which i think our
tachyon emitters which we know can
affect Manhattan's powers will be used
to weaken him allowing some sort of
transference of power lori may also be
used as bait considering the history
manhattan and her have instead of it
being used to transfer power it might
also be used to just turn Keene into a
new doctor Manhattan type character
while lady Tru gives a speech of all of
her accomplishments including building a
micro fusion spacecraft intent Angela
breaks into what she believes to be
wills room only to find her attached to
a sedated elephant remember back to the
tutorial video that in order to get the
nostalgia flushed out of her neurons
she'll need a lot of cerebral spinal
fluid provided by a natural host and
what better hosts than an elephant - as
a brain three times larger than a
human's and over three times the amount
of neurons it probably has a lot of that
fluid she needs take a look again at the
true logo an elephant trunk has been
staring at us the whole time back in
Vietnam June Angela's grandmother saves
her from a life at the girl's home only
to die a few hours later we learned that
Angela's father and her had a falling
out after he went to join the army
hence why she's only coming into the
picture now I also like the graffiti in
the background here dr. Manhattan with
blood on his hands with the word
murderer the Vietnamese people must
really hate him for his crimes during
the war Angelou awakens and makes her
escape only to stumble upon a dark room
with a blue sphere of the world as she
clicks on different cities we see this
device is hooked up to the Manhattan
phone booth which Tru owns the same one
Laura used to send messages to Manhattan
true arrives and call
them unanswered prayers Manhattan isn't
even on Mars he's here in Tulsa
pretending to be human as she says this
Ozymandias theme plays in the background
another hint that she could be related
to him she says the 7th cavalry is
planning to capture Manhattan destroy
him then become him which Angela thinks
is just crazy talk but lady true gets
the last word wondering why Angela
hasn't asked who dr. Manhattan is that's
because she knows it's Cal outside
Angela's home two men wearing war shack
mass watch one of the best lines of this
episode had to do with not being able to
tell whether or not someone is good or
bad when they're wearing a mask could
one of these two be looking glass my
guess is No now this is easy to miss but
there's also this device covered up in
the back of the truck my guess is that
it will be used to help capture
Manhattan and teleport him to the
abandoned mall or perhaps help suppress
his powers inside the a bar home kal
sleeps with a copy of Ernest Hemingway's
For Whom the Bell Tolls the story of a
man who knows he's going to die soon but
still falls in love with a young woman
if next week's preview is any indication
we'll see how Angela and Manhattan's
plan came to fruition Angela takes out a
hammer and Cal doesn't seem to remember
any of their plan a plan which she says
was his idea in the first place
Cal was never in an accident it was a
lie so they could be together for a
while
she bashes his head in with a hammer and
takes out this magnetic ring from his
forehead which may be some sort of
device that was restricting his powers
all we know is that when it was removed
the real dr. Manhattan emerges which we
see a tiny glimpse up through the
reflection on her pupils the episode
ends with David Boies life on Mars a
cheeky nod to Manhattan not having been
on Mars all this time with only two
episodes left this season is shaping up
to be one of the best shows of 2019 I
hope you'll like and subscribe as I plan
on releasing more watchman videos and
make sure to leave your thoughts and
theories in the comments below you can
also follow me on twitter at things
story
yt until next time remember daddy loves
you very much